les étrangers pouvait-il participer à la
vie politique sous la révolution
ça c'est la grosse question alors
effectivement contrairement souvent à
des lectures rétrospective la
citoyenneté et la nationalité à l'époque
de la révolution française en 1789 comme
en 1792 ne sont pas complètement
intriquées l'une dans l'autre
je vais prendre juste un exemple
quelques exemples en tout cas qui me
paraissent particulièrement important
1792 proclamation de la république mise
en place de la convention et telus entre
autres à la convention un homme qui est
à l'époque célébrissime qui s'appelle
thomas spain qui a été sujet de sa
gracieuse majesté britannique par
conséquent qui ensuite a pris fait et
cause pour les révolutionnaires et les
insurgés américains et qui devenu
citoyen américain et qui lorsque la
révolution française éclate vient en
france il n'est pas français
il n'a pas la nationalité française il
ne parle pas un traître mot de français
et pour que tant il est élu à la
convention nationale
non seulement il est élu à la convention
nationale mais il est membre du comité
de constitution dont il faut rappeler
que c'est ce comité dont la fonction la
responsabilité est de proposer à la
convention la première constitution
républicaine de ce crime et il élabore
effectivement avec un autre élu très
célèbre à l'époque et encore aujourd'hui
assez connue pour un certain nombre de
ses prises de position qui est condorcet
et donc condorcet et thomas spain qui
encore une fois n'a pas la nationalité
française vont élaborer le premier
projet de concession républicain de ce
prix qui va être présenté à la
convention et qui va être rejetée ceci
pour souligner que pour les
révolutionnaires 7,92 en particulier et
c'est républicain
le critère est témoin un critère de
nationalité qu'un critère politique et
il ne voyait absolument aucun problème à
intégrer donc des étrangers prenant fait
et cause pour la révolution prenant fait
et cause pour la république à leur
accorder des responsabilités et encore
une fois des responsabilités extrêmement
importante puisque thomas spain a
participé à l'élaboration de la halle
fondamentale
bon moment